please welcome rachel zugler
[Applause]
oh my
to see you again god to see you too we
had so much fun the other night i did oh
i'm so happy to see you i'm so happy to
see you i heard you saw the movie
steven showed me a a video that you sent
him after was it stephen it was stephen
it was um i i couldn't stop laughing
solely because every time you tried to
say something you just started crying
again
and he was like you could tell her that
i showed you i won't show anyone else
but it's very sweet and i'm so glad you
loved it enough to cry very hard over it
i ugly cried yeah truly i mean it really
starts at this one interval of the movie
um it has to do with rita moreno oh yeah
i know it's someone you had a picture of
her in your locker
i had a purple dress the purple dress on
the rooftop singing america i was upset
i wanted to be anita when i was growing
up which is so funny now considering but
i
i was obsessed with her and and there
was this picture literally this photo in
my locker hanging up um and and i just
can't believe that i got to go to work
every day and see her sitting there very
quietly before she would start something
with raucous laughter and tell us all
these incredible stories she has she is
just so incredible
and
i was talking to stephen
and he certainly changed my life of
course and he
how's he changing changed mine too i
mean
it's really wild and that's why meeting
you is so incredible because i knew what
an impact he had had on your life in
such such a such a different way such a
deeper way than he did on mine but a way
nonetheless no and the same
i think he walked into both of our lives
and turned them both upside down on our
heads yeah and for the better yes he
took care of us yeah he continues to do
that it's that's the and
oh my goodness opportunities that nobody
else said i mean you did you you beat
out 30 000 people for this
[Applause]
he saw
in you and i remember talking to him at
a party
and he said i've met the one i've met
this girl who has changed everything
i've of all the people i've met with
you know throughout the years let alone
in this he sparkled it
you know where's that connection like
do you have any objectivity into what he
sees in you oh god it wasn't really and
it's so funny that you say that because
i was just talking to my team about it
the other day after they saw the film
and
they they
told me and i guess i agree that i was
shot in that movie with such love in
mind and and it was unlike anything i've
ever witnessed in a film before and i
never wanted to be in movies that was
never the original plan for my life but
then after seeing the way that
that stephen shot the movie and shot
maria there was so much care that went
into her there's so much care involved
with telling it as accurately as
possible as well and that that was a
huge thing for me growing up and not
realizing that the story wasn't
necessarily accurate until i was a
teenager and realized that you know
natalie wood may god rest her soul she
was russian she didn't know our lived
experiences as latinos in this in this
united states and yet you were convinced
of her absolutely and appreciated her in
the movie but this was different this
was way different this was about
honoring uh latinx people the community
and making sure that everything was
was accurate was represented and it
meant so much to me that tony kushner
our incredible screenwriter took the
time to make so much research to put
together these panels where people came
together to tell us about what it was
like to live in these 20 bad blocks
called san juan hill where these
low-income communities were living where
puerto ricans were migrating to and it
was all being demolished in the name of
lincoln center for the performing arts
where these low-income families wouldn't
even be able to go and enjoy
entertainment they couldn't afford it it
wasn't for them they were just being
displaced and that's my ancestors
stories and therefore
it's the story of so many people in this
country and being able to bring that to
life is is an honor that i will i will
never uh i will never forget
well i am so excited
to try
and
do justice in an entire week that we are
celebrating west side story week on the
show um you're here ariana's here ansel
is here um we've got you've got you've
got the trio i heard that you've got
mike david and josh
who that's ours
[Applause]
okay now before we go if it's okay since
we've talked so much about you maria you
know steven everything yeah can i give
you a final five oh my goodness okay a
little insight into you for all of us
yes okay here we go all right all right
we're going to do the final oh my god
okay here we go
all right nervous oh my god okay
um what is the last lie you told oh my
god that i that i wasn't too tired to do
something that's so honest
[ __ ] exhausted okay one detail about
uh behind the scenes maybe we wouldn't
know
um
bruce springsteen came to set to watch
me do i feel pretty and i couldn't go up
to him because i'm from new jersey and
that meant the world to me
okay that is the best details ever oh
it's awesome okay what's your latest
food craving sushi at all times i want
sushi no matter what we're doing it's
breakfast i want sushi okay it's sunday
what's your favorite movie right now
just to put on on a sunday singing in
the rain oh yeah
stanley dawn and give it to me
all right a song that we all need to put
into heavy rotation right now um i think
ain't it fun by paramore is always my
pump yes that's what he said yes yes
oh rachel
be sure to enrich your life and move
forward in the way that steven spielberg
wants us to
by seeing west side story um in theaters
december 10th only in theaters william
peters as he wanted it to be
and you must be on the big screen please
um thank you
[Music]